[Music]
straight ahead all
law and crime daily a hearing over
whether to remove the prosecutor of the
so-called doomsday cult couple
what was said to laurie valo's sister on
a secret recording about chad daybell
and he uses this kind of i call it
spiritual abuse spiritual manipulation
no charges will be filed against police
officers in the shooting of a man left
paralyzed
our experts break down the kenosha
district attorney's decision in the
jacob blake case
so it is our decision that no charge
will be filed
plus a judge sentences a mother to five
years in prison
for the death of her daughter a look
back at the pajama pants strangulation
trial
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin
defense attorneys for the so-called
doomsday couple are trying to get the
prosecutor removed from the case
lori valo and her husband chad dabel are
charged with concealing altering and
destroying evidence in connection with
the deaths of valo's two children
the bodies of seven-year-old j.j valo
and 16-year-old tyler ryan were found
buried in a shallow grave in dave bell's
idaho property
the couple was arrested last year in
hawaii but neither are facing charges
for murder
now their defense claims the prosecutor
tried to intimidate valo's sister and
sister-in-law
during a meeting in arizona an attorney
for the two women
secretly recorded the meeting and were
hearing it for the first time
during a court hearing in this case our
goal is to have such a strong case
that when she has confident counsel i
don't know if you notice her attorney's
never handled a felony before
um he has never
never done any meaningful criminal work
at all
and he doesn't know what he's doing he's
a nice guy
yeah he's lying about me but he uh
but he's he doesn't know what he's doing
and one
once we file further charges she will be
appointed
counsel who will know what they're doing
and our goal is to
put together such a case that they're
smart enough to say
uh it's gonna be better to talk
so i i'm so torn with all of it's such a
conflicting feeling to know that this
person's been good her whole life and
then has made
this errand judgment and got accepted
into this vortex of this man
and i feel for her
i just have so much compassion towards
her because i know that's not what
she would have ever done on her own
right and so she paid the price for this
forever and i hate that for her so i'm
very
conflicted but i was going to ask you on
the concealment or
not the concealment but on the
conspiracy to commit murder what's the
weight of that in terms of joseph is
that a death penalty thing or
it is a death penalty case now do you
are you planning to ask for that for
them or do you we sure hope we don't
a lot of that will depend on her
the defense called the attorney for the
two women to testify he was at the
meeting with the prosecutor rob wood
and summer schifflett and is the one who
recorded it
a flag went off in my mind when he
brought his deputy in to meet
my client and myself um and to kind of
do this introduction stuff
and that's when i got my recorder out
and turned it on um
it that put a flag off in my mind that
this wasn't going to be hey i'm john
i'm rob um you know this is my deputy
you know
good luck today thanks for doing this
and we'll talk to you when it's all done
i didn't think it was going to be
inappropriate i thought it was going to
be adversarial
and the fact that he was backing himself
up with a witness
told me at least it made my you know the
flag
the spider senses whatever you want to
call it the defense instinct
that i need to be recording this
conversation because he's got a witness
in here i need to have my
recorder running i had no idea that the
conversation was going to go the
direction that it went
and mr wood attempting to influence
summer shiplet
uh to testify a certain way would you
agree with that
again i don't know what his intents were
but it
i can't see any other reason to tell her
the things that he did other than to
steer her in that direction
and when you say steer you mean
influence do you not correct
it's another word for that yes on cross
an attorney for prosecutor rob wood
pointed out that schifflett and her
attorney never objected during the
meeting
i was doing what my client wanted to do
which was to participate in this
interview and you got to understand
i wasn't running it she was running it i
was there as legal counsel
and she wanted to do this interview she
wanted to give testimony
she'd been asked to give testimony um in
that sense and so she was going to do
that i didn't want to shut this down
but that doesn't that doesn't take away
the concerns that i had at the time
there also wasn't a forum to go to
you know if i've got a problem with the
question you're asking i could object to
it
in a setting not not in this setting
it's not my position here
but there's a judge to go to or let's
table this right now and
straighten this out in a deposition or
something like that but
it wasn't that type of setting this was
unique like i said i've done this type
of setting many many times but
to have this kind of conversation was
was a little bit
oh we're doing this okay and i i
didn't know where it was going to go i
knew i was recording it and i could deal
with it later
joining us is attorney dina dahl and
terry austin deena
no one more than a brooklyn public
defender wishes they can throw out a
prosecutor
for chorusing a witness but i don't know
if the law is on their side
what did you think of their arguments
and what you saw so far
i think that argument is actually pretty
persuasive it is
sacrificed that we cannot tamper with
witnesses especially a prosecutor
because the whole point of a witness is
to give evidence in a case and if you
start to
tamper or influence that that evidence
is meaningless and so these rules around
how
an attorney and especially a prosecutor
is supposed to be contacting themselves
with a witness so i i think this is
actually a pretty strong argument on the
defensive side
yeah terry you kind of agreed that you
we talked about this before the defense
brought an expert
with an interesting view speaking about
witnesses and the science behind it
make some sense of this how do you think
this will affect the uh the outcome of
the hearing
look i think dina makes a very good
point and the forensic psychologist
that the defense called he was excellent
but i actually don't think
that his testimony is going to change
the outcome and here's why i think the
motion is going to be denied
and i think prosecutorial misconduct is
a very
high standard and i don't think it
happened here i don't think that there
was
coercion in the sense that we would
think of it
and this type of behavior i think might
have been a bit too
far maybe too personal but i don't think
it was misconception
yeah there's coercion as we understand
and there's also coercion as a law and
the court see it we'll see if those two
fit still ahead on law and crime daily
sentencing in the pajama pan
strangulation case
out of iowa plus the district attorney's
decision over whether to charge officers
accused of shooting a man in the back
the video and shocking announcement next
[Music]
following a month-long review the
district attorney in kenosha wisconsin
announces
the officers involved in the shooting of
jacob blake will not be
charged and neither will blake law and
crime's angenette levy breaks down the
da's
what the d.a says led him to that
decision
brian you may recall jacob blake was
shot seven times last summer in that
confrontation with kenosha police
d.a michael gravely says he's not going
to file charges because he believes the
officer who fired those shots
would successfully be able to argue
self-defense at trial
this was a tragedy first and foremost
for jacob blake
who still suffers from grievous injuries
d.a michael gravely spent nearly two
hours explaining his decision
if you do not have a case you can prove
beyond a reasonable doubt
as you're going to hear me talk about
then you're ethically obligated not to
charge such a case
the chain of events that led to jacob
lake started last
august when his ex-girlfriend called
9-1-1 for help
saying blake was going to crash her car
and had done it before
on top of that he's not supposed to be
here today was his own birthday so i'll
allow him
to spend a couple hours with him but
he's not giving me the key to this
friend
and that's all i'm asking for there was
a felony warrant out for blake's arrest
for domestic violence and sexual assault
those charges were for an incident
involving blake's ex
when they come across jacob blake they
must
attempt to arrest him gravely says it's
not seen
on the video but even blake admitted he
resisted arrest and officers made three
attempts to bring him under control with
a taser
gravely says blake even admitted he was
armed with a knife
and then tries to go to his car
struggling with officers
blake's children were inside that
vehicle
officer ruston chefsky fired seven times
those actions deemed reasonable by a
use-of-force
expert
jacob blake remains paralyzed he pleaded
guilty to two charges in december
and prosecutors dropped a third degree
sexual assault charge against him
his family disappointed by the decision
to say the least
this is a slap in the face
by wisconsin government and the d.a
and et cetera what has happened has
perpetuated systemic racism
we are immensely disappointed with that
decision we believe that
there is more than sufficient evidence
to find probable cause
to charge officer chesky
this case was not presented to a grand
jury the district attorney said that he
consulted with a neutral use of force
expert and that use of force expert is a
former police chief he said that jacob
blake had both
the opportunity and the intent to harm
those officers with his knife
the fact that blake turned
his body in that regard was in and
thrust the knife forward that was an
example of intent
this is probably the question that i
have been
been asked the most why
seven shots now
first officers in the state of wisconsin
are trained to shoot until the threat
has stopped
that forms forms basis
and that expert noble ray said that
officer chesky stopped firing or said he
stopped firing
once jacob blake dropped his knife the
d.a also said that officer chesky
provided immediate aid
to jacob blake following that shooting
brian
thanks ange wisconsin district attorneys
typically present their evidence to a
judge rather than a grand jury
but it appears that a preliminary
hearing did not occur in this case
the d.a said his decision to decline to
file charges relied on evidence that
officer chesky was confronted with the
following
an armed man with a felony warrant blake
resisting arrest
blake appearing to be about to flee with
a child the d.a says
that's when the officer decided to
re-engage
joining me again is dina doll and terry
austin along with angenette levy
dina the neutral expert can tell what
blake's intent was
and a felony warrant means self-defense
that's not the law that i practice
can you make sense of this you know he
wasn't
neutral to the extent that a jury or
judge would be
because the prosecutor here isn't
necessarily supposed to be
neutral right but they are supposed to
decide whether or not they can bring the
state's
trial and so they didn't necessarily
rely on somebody that's neutral
the problem here is that we have seen
something like this
over and over and people are going to
stop believing
in our institutions of justice which
creates
a huge problem for us as society whether
or not in this particular case yes they
want to be able to arrest somebody
who is playing with a child and has a
felony arrest warrant
but the fact that the police officer yet
again came into a situation here
where a black man was shot so many times
it's just one too many times and i think
they should have brought it in front of
a judge
so people could feel a sense that there
was an impartial arbiter here
absolutely initial report said jacob
blate was shot
in the back about seven times but the
d.a said that's
not the case what did you learn yeah the
the d.a said
during that press conference brian that
he asked the milwaukee county
medical examiner to kind of look at
those wounds and make a determination
the best they can tell they say that
jacob blake was shot four times in the
back
and three times on his left side which
they believe is consistent with that
movement they described with him
twisting his body with that knife in his
hand
thanks angeanette coming up on law and
crime daily two detectives fired in the
brianna taylor case
what led the police chief to make the
terminations official
plus how one defendant managed to escape
a courthouse
the shocking video you don't want to
miss
[Music]
two of the officers involved in the
brianna taylor case have officially been
fired
detectives joshua jaynes and miles
cosgroves were terminated from the
louisville police department
chief yvette gentry had notified the men
last week and the terminations went into
effect on tuesday
briana taylor was killed in march by
police inside her home jane's author of
the no knock warrant
he's accused of lying about information
that suspicious packages
were sent to taylor's home cosgrove is
accused of firing the bullet that killed
taylor
a third detective brett hankinson was
fired in july he remains the only one
charged in the case but not for taylor's
death
defendants should know that just because
you plead not guilty to a crime
doesn't mean you can just walk free long
crime founder and host of a
e series court camp tells us about one
inmate who had another idea
let's kick things off in the benton
county justice center in washington
state
where a judge has found gerald hyde ii
guilty of methamphetamine possession
with the arraignment now over he's being
taken back to jail
or is he
the defendant has slipped away from
security and re-entered the courtroom
[Music]
he strips off his prison-issue shirt
and uses it to hide his handcuffs
[Music]
he makes it to the hallway and after a
quick look around
he takes off
along the way he ditches the distinctive
orange
prison-issue shoes and continues
barefoot through the courthouse
quickly makes his way to the lobby until
he exits
straight through the front doors and out
onto the street
all before anyone seemingly even noticed
he was missing
but within two hours police catch up
with him hiding in a friend's house
he's immediately taken back into custody
and get this he later decided to
represent himself on the escape charge
the jury took all but 13 minutes to
convict him he was later sentenced to
two years and two months in prison
when we come back a mother accused of
killing her daughter with a pair of
pajama pants
learns how much time she'll spend in
jail a judge's sentence after the break
an iowa mother convicted of strangling
her daughter with a pair of pajama pants
was
sentenced to five years in prison
authorities say kelsey thomas purposely
killed five-year-old chloe in 2018.
a jury last year acquitted thomas of
child endangerment resulting in death
but was hung
on first-degree murder prosecutors move
for a second trial
and thomas chose to be tried by a judge
rather than a jury
the judge found thomas guilty of
involuntary manslaughter ruling that she
believed the defendant's actions were
quote
in a fit of anger and frustration not
premeditation
as the state suggested the defendant
told chloe
you're gonna take a nap or i'm gonna
beat you because she wanted to make sure
she could grasp chloe
like any other normal five-year-old
didn't want to take a nap
so she ran away from that bed
and what did her mother do she took
those pajama pants
she threw them over her pulled back
and strangled her with those pajama
pants
in chloe's last moments on this earth
she would fight for her life staring at
her
own mother we know that the defendant
intended to do this act she intended to
cause injury to chloe chandler
there is no other intent when you take
pajama pants and use them in the way
that she did
the judge's decision was based in part
on this so-called confession from one of
thomas's police interviews
and she had jumped out of her bed
and i tried to grab her i tried her long
and she slipped out of my arm
i grabbed the pants and went like this
[Music]
um
[Music]
the defense claimed little chloe
accidentally hanged herself and called
their own forensic pathologist
to demonstrate how she could have tried
to free herself
from the pajama pants there are a wide
variety of situations in which this can
basically form a three-quarter inch in
diameter
transverse mark on the neck one of them
is to have it in this particular
situation
this is probably about 5 8 of an inch
which is a little bit less than three
quarters
but even having something like this
which is basically stretched out
and even maybe which may or may not have
been twisted in any ways
could have certainly made some kind of a
market as well
having the presence of seams as well
where these are
items that are a little stiffer and that
they project could
also make certain kinds of marks in the
neck that would be
narrower
so this particular kind of garment is
is capable of making those kinds of
marks on the child's neck
in my opinion terry
unlike me hindsight is 20 20. do you
think the defense regrets
doing a bench trial the second time
around or is five years some sort of
victory for them
oh brian this is a huge victory for the
defense there's no question that kelsey
killed her daughter the only question
was whether or not it was intentional or
voluntary and for whatever reason
this judge ruled that the prosecution
didn't prove
that the death was premeditated or
intentional and i think the fact
that kelsey lied multiple times to me
shows that it was intentional or at
least premeditated and look
five years is nothing defense got off
with a really good break here
and so i think she'll be out of jail in
no time with time served
all right so dina terry thinks five
years is nothing but i want to ask you
the same question five years
too light too heavy what do you think
about the sentence
well she received a maximum sentence for
involuntary manslaughter which
was which was what she was convicted of
and i think that the judge
saw this correctly she said this was a
frustrated
tired mother who did not intend to kill
her daughter but in the moment did
and felt remorseful about it and that
just rings true with what we know about
this she was trying the mother was
trying to take a nap
first you went on a late shift for work
and unfortunately
she was really overwhelmed it is a
tragedy that the child would
die here but this goes to show how much
mothers
really need support especially a working
mother with a young child
right well thank you dina and thank you
terry for joining us and thank you for
joining us here at the law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you